alors il ya quelques jours le
gouvernement américain le département de
l'agriculture des états unis a décidé de
ne pas réguler un nouveau champignon ogm
qui ne bruni pas et c'est un jour pignon
ogm qui a été obtenu avec la méthode
christopher cazenove qui est une méthode
révolutionnaire et ça ça pose énormément
de problèmes de bioéthique et c'est ce
dont on va parler pas mal dans cette
vidéo
mais avant cela laissez-moi expliquer un
petit peu comment fonctionne christopher
kas 9 cette technologie révolutionnaire
avant de parler de crise par cazenove
qu'il faut que je vous parle de l'adn
d'alors l'adn j'imagine que vous avez
déjà entendu parler de ça c'est la
molécule du vivant elle a une forme
assez géométriquement très élégante de
double hélice et à chaque brin d'aneth
chaque morceau adn est une scop elbaz
nucléiques et on peut la représenter par
une lettre il ya quatre bases du clic
différentes donc on a utilisé quatre
lettres pour les représenter à tlc et
j'ai en rien un truc qui s'appelle la rn
qui a un petit peu comme l'adn je veux
pas rentrer dans les détails de
différence entre adn et rn je parle
assez générique mende adn pour
simplifier alors que parfois ce sera de
la rn si vous voulez plus de précisions
vous invite à aller voir la vidéo de de
david voir sur science étonnante est
aussi un super épisode de podcasts ans à
ce sujet bref pour donner un cadre de
cette vidéo ce qui est important à
retenir c'est que notre code génétique
c'est finalement une suite de lettres
une suite de ces quatre lettres ça colle
bien sûr tous les aspects physiques et
de notre corps mais aussi des aspects
plus comportementaux et la méthode de
christophe cazenove ça qu'elle permet de
faire c'est d'éviter le code adn c'est à
dire avec capable en gros de changer la
suite des lettres qui composent notre
adn
et ça c'est comme assez fou quand on y
pense mais capable d'écrire quasiment le
double vivons donc l'idée de chris paul
cassia c'est une fille mais c'est un
morceau de l'adn donc ce morceau d'adr
il veut être un peu spécial dans une
extrémité il va y avoir en partie de
gènes codant pour kas neuf qui va être
une protéine dont on va reparler et
ensuite on a un long morceau adn qui est
une alternance ion2 d'espèces de paul
situation des ponctuations qui
correspond à une suite précise de
lettres qui se trouve être un parent
drogue les gens rentrent pas dans les
détails
et entre deux pointus à sion on a un
message et ce message là c'est
l'équivalent de ce qu'on rentre dans le
contrôle f c'est à dire c'est un morceau
suite de lettres de l'adn que l'on va
chercher à identifier
par exemple dans l'adn d'une cellule de
champignons ou une cellule humaine
donc c'est la partie que l'on cherche à
identifier dans l'adn que l'on cherche à
manipuler et ensuite donc l'adn crise
parce qu'il va faire c'est ce morceau là
il va essayer de se coller un endroit
qui a un morceau adn qui est identique à
ceux à lui-même est typiquement ça va
être donc les morceaux adn cible mars la
partie des deux morceaux la dette qu'on
veut identifier battre du coup coller à
ce morceau l'adn et ensuite les enzymes
cazenove qui ont été produites par la
fin de partie l'adn ils vont venir
englober la partie des deux adn qui
étaient collés l'un à l'autre
elle va venir couper claque toute cette
partie là de l'adn du coup ça va couper
en gros l'adn
on cherche à manipuler en trois parties
les deux parties sur les côtés et la
partie qu'on cherche à enlever et cette
partie qui va être enlevée donc elle va
être coupé va être enlevée et les deux
autres morceaux l'adn de façon naturelle
vont venir se recoller ce qu'on appelle
la recomposition homologue alors on peut
faire encore mieux que ça puisque si on
veut on peut même rajouter un autre
morceau d'adn qui va venir s'interposer
entre les deux autres morceaux de l'adn
et du coup on va pouvoir insérer en plus
de couper vos points insérez un autre
morceau daden à l'intérieur du génome de
l'adn comme on cherche à manipuler et
cette méthode là en gohelle permet
vraiment de d'éditer de l'adn de
quasiment lettre par lettre choisir ce
que l'on veut couper et par quoi on veut
le remplacer
donc les spurs 15,9 ça a été inventé il
ya quelques années et c'est la
révolution passe a complètement changé
ce qui est fait dans tous les
laboratoires de biologie de biologie
moléculaire à travers le monde
à partir du moment où on va étudier les
faits par exemple d'un morceau de gênes
sur le phénotype c'est à dire les les
apparences physiques d'un animal ou
d'une bactérie
eh ben on va faire cette opération qui
est sparkasse 9 en enlevant typiquement
un bouddha dn que l'on pense être
important et voir ce que ça implique sur
l'animal et du coup on va pouvoir à
ferrer par rapport à ça qu'est-ce qui
est qu'est-ce qui fait quoi à
l'intérieur du morceau d'adr et ça ça
peut changer complètement notre
compréhension de l'adn qui aujourd'hui
il faut que le dire est encore très très
limité on sait pas trop à quoi servent
une grosse partie de la dernière qu'une
poignée de deux gènes de fractions l'adn
dont on comprend à peu près le
fonctionnement mais bien sûr au delà de
son application dans la recherche en
biologie crise par cazenove semble avoir
des terres potentiel d'applications
énorme en dehors de deux du champ de la
recherche et notamment dans ce qu'on
appelle les ogm c'est à dire les
organismes génétiquement modifiés
notamment à des fins agricoles et donc
il ya quelques jours le département de
l'agriculture aux états unis a accepté
que l'on enlève un bon d'adé end un
certain champignons kiko des pour une
protéine qui brunit c'est le champignon
du coup maintenant un échantillon qui
brunit son bord et qui peuvent se
conserver plus longtemps et ça c'est
quand même vraiment cool quoi si on
c'est d'oublier un petit peu des trucs
de les problèmes associés à la
bioéthique juste d'un point de vue un
génie c'est vraiment cool qu'on soit
capable de créer des champignons qui va
non une plus longue durée de vie où on
peut les conserver plus longtemps
juste en enlevant un morceau d adn comme
c'est quand même vraiment classe qu
après bien sûr ça pose d'énormes
problèmes de bioéthique puisque l'heure
n'est vraiment capable de jouer de façon
plus fondamentale qu'avant avec la
nature du vivant et son code génétique
c'est quand même assez calme ça fait
peur que george fisher vous avez déjà
plus un avis sur les ogm que vous avez
une vie même un avis très tranché nous
est même pull trappe artisans peut-être
d'un côté plutôt que de l'autre
et avant de parler vraiment de
bioéthique ce que j'aimerais que vous
fassiez c'est l'effort de réfléchir
vraiment aux raisons profondes qui font
que vous pensez ce que vous pensez et
non pas aux raisons logiques qui font
que vous pensez ce que vous pensez mais
plus eu raison sociétal ce que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on pense
en général vient de l'environnement est
en fait moi j'avais un avis tranché
hyper tranchée mais assez tranché sur la
question il ya un an et je me suis rendu
compte petit à petit que la raison pour
laquelle j'avais la vie que j'avais
était essentiellement dû à mon entourage
à tous mes amis tous mes professeurs qui
me qui avait tout façon très subtile et
parfois inconsciente parfois sans faire
exprès donner leur avis sur celle sur
leur position et me conduisait à penser
la même chose que sans que j'y
réfléchisse vraiment précis jamais pour
nous pris le temps avant il ya quelques
années de penser vraiment à au rôle que
pouvait jouer les ogm dans notre société
et pourquoi ça prouve ce rôle pouvait
être positif ou négatif est en fait
depuis que je me suis vraiment plus
intéressé à la question notamment en
écoutant ce superbe épisode de podcasts
ion dont l'opinion est maligne éthiques
ont énormément évolué un peu dans tous
les sens et surtout je me suis rendu
compte que tout ce que je pensais avant
c'était pas une opinion réfléchisse et
poserait pas pris le temps de réfléchir
ce que j'aimerais que vous fassiez avant
avancez un peu plus c'est juste prendre
un peu le temps de réfléchir à pourquoi
est-ce que je pense ce que je pense
pourquoi est ce que vous pensez ce que
vous pensez qui je pense est la question
la plus la plus intéressante de tout
quoi doit toujours se demander mais
pourquoi un tel pensent ce qu'ils
pensent et pourquoi moi je pense que je
pense que sachant qu'il est peut-être
plus facile de commencer par la question
pourquoi est ce que intel pensent ce
qu'ils pensent parce que c'est toujours
très difficile de se remettre en cause
et de se demander vraiment pourquoi
est-ce que je pense ce que je pense
j'aimerais aussi insisté sur le fait que
je ne suis pas biologiste je ne suis pas
un expert en politique
ce que je veux faire c'est vous fait
réfléchir c'est pas forcer une opinion
que vous avez le droit d'être en
désaccord sur tout ce que je vais dire
et j'essaierai de bien répondre assuré
kim des choses mais c'est un débat je
pense que c'est vraiment un débat qui
est ouvert
personne n'a le monopole marie biotique
mais c'est un débat qui doit être bien
informé est ce que je vais essayer de le
faire dans la suite cessé de mettre en
perspective les ogm dans un contexte de
biologie plus plus globale de qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en biologie depuis tout
ce temps et ce qui peut se faire d'un
point de vue technologique
quels sont les potentiels les
possibilités qu'offre d'avant crise peur
kasman casse neuf et je vais faire un
petit peu de silence dans cette vidéo
pour vous preniez le temps de vraiment
réfléchir à pourquoi vous pensez ce que
vous pensez vraiment une question ultra
pas monter patiente et c est ça se
résout pas en 5 secondes
je vous invite vraiment imposé poser
poser cette question très régulièrement
pendant des semaines des mois des années
c'est vraiment la question la plus
intéressante de tout je pense comprendre
pourquoi est ce qu'on pense ce qu'on
pense
ok on va passer à la bioéthique on va
voir pourquoi certains arguments
classiques anti ogm ne sont pas si
rigoureux que ça ait son papa qui sont
faux mais c'est souvent ils sont un peu
banques donc
le premier argument le plus classique
c'est bien sûr que les ogm c'est pas
naturel et il ya pas mal de trucs qui
vont pas avec cette phrase mais pour
commencer on peut dire que les ogm sont
ultra naturel par le truc plus naturelle
qui soit c'est les ogm c'est la loi
théorie de l'évolution de darwin ne fait
que les animaux quand ils se
reproduisent vrai il ya des petites
modifications génétiques à des
hybridations et des nouvelles formes
d'aden qui apparaissent et que au fur et
à mesure certaine forme d'adr
disparaissent d'autres apparaissent du
coup bon vivant est constamment en train
d'être génétiquement modifiés en fait
c'est la base du vivant comme d'être
génétiquement modifiés mais vous me
direz peut-être que les ogm eux sont
humainement modifiés sont
artificiellement modifié et oui c'est
vrai mais il ya plein d'animaux qui sont
artificiellement modifié et c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'article sélection
artificielle par opposition à la
sélection naturelle la section naturel
c'est celle qui se passe dans la nature
dans la savane dans jungle ou dans la
montée du gouffre dans la nature alors
que la sélection artificielle c'est
celle qui est imposé par l'homme si vous
ai réfléchi et si vous y réfléchissez un
petit peu il ya énormément d'animaux et
d'espèces végétales quasiment tout qui
sont artificiellement lee fier quand on
fait de l'agriculture tout ce qu'on fait
c'est c'est de la sélection artificielle
choisi les graines qui vont être plantés
en fonction de leurs attributs l'année
passée du coup on sélectionne vraiment
ce qui va se reproduire
donc ça s'use de la sélection
artificielle mais parfois on fait aussi
de l'hybridation l'hybridation mais
c'est vraiment faim c'est jouer à dieu
quoi c'est c'est manipuler génétiquement
c'est choisir le gel de certaines
nouvelles et mélanger à cargèse d'intel
on va faire le mélange et on voit ce
qu'on n'obtient pas ça c'est de l'eau
j'aime déjà et en faisant ça on a fait
des trucs incroyables si vous y
réfléchissez un petit peu les fruits ton
âme et son optimisé pour être mangés
regardez une banane qu'on a aujourd'hui
versus une banane telle qu'on la trouve
en état sauvage mais s'ajuste rien à
voir et la bannette d'aujourd'hui est
bien meilleure beaucoup plus de beaucoup
plus à manger déjà depuis plus de plus
de bondues tribaux et cetera que est en
fait depuis cent mille ans que l'homme
sait
sédentarisés et qu'il a fait de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage tout ce
qui les entoure tout ce qui est autour
de lui sont proches et artificiellement
génétiquement modifiées on vit entourée
d' ogm
l'autre remarque qu'il faut faire sur
l'argument selon lesquelles les ogm sont
pas naturels c'est bien sûr que ce qui
est naturel n'est pas forcément mieux
quoi il ya plein de trucs naturel qui
vous tuerai en un instant puis si vous
préférez les trucs naturelle allait
manger la banane d'antan que la banane
nature c'est dégueu quoi et des fouilles
et des noyaux énorme
il n'y a pas de nutriments et en fait
depuis cent mille ans grâce à la
sélection artificielle
on a une nourriture plus abondante que
jamais de meilleure qualité que jamais
qui permet de nourrir aujourd'hui le
monde entier que pour pas complètement
je n'en tiens pas ce qui est encore la
faim dans le monde mais on est capable
de produire beaucoup plus à manger que
il ya cent ans que dire il ya cent ans
il y avait des risques de famine que et
à son bilan
bref tout ça pour dire que l'argument
les ogm c'est pas naturel
c'est un argument qui est faux sur tous
les points quasiment tous les maux de
cette phrase sont problématiques
un autre argument qui est beaucoup plus
recevable c'est le principe de
précaution est en effet quand on met des
ogm des trucs qui n'ont jamais existé
avant on peut se demander
si ça va pas faire des maladies qu'on
n'a pas vu avant si ça va pas faire ça
va pas tuer toute la biodiversité aux
alentours ou des fous dangereux et ça
c'est clairement un problème mais ce
n'est pas un problème spécifique aux ogm
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres techniques
comme les radiations ou l'hybridation
qui créent des nouvelles espèces 50
prend deux espèces différentes et qu'on
essaie de les mettre ensemble et de
faire un nouveau truc ça fait une
nouvelle espèce qu'on n'est pas capable
d'anticiper les conséquences sur sa pire
encore quand on importe une agriculture
qui s'est fait à l'autre bout du monde
et qu'on importe ton en europe est bon
mais en place en europe tout un tout
tout tout une nouvelle espèce tout plein
de nouveaux gènes qui n'ont jamais
tendre en paix dont on ne connaît pas
les interactions notamment avec
l'environnement local ou avec la
génétique des personnes qui vivent en
europe ce qui était planté ailleurs et
mortelle en europe on sait pas est en
fait le risque dans ce qu'elle a peut
paraître beaucoup plus grand en fait
qu'avec des ogm puisque avec des ogm
notamment ceux avec la technique crise
peur kasman 15 nov
on est capable de modifier localement
nick mans là les jeunes que l'on veut
modifier donc on contrôle beaucoup lieu
avec chris marquès 9
les modifications génétiques on apporte
un une espèce animale ou végétale tout
cas beaucoup mieux que si on faisait de
l'hybridation qui a un truc un peu là je
vois ce qui sort veut dire dans
l'histoire de l'humanité un des pires en
menant un des moments les plus violents
pour leur biodiversité céder sans doute
rien à plein mais par exemple
l'introduction de la patate en europe
patate jamais existé en europe s'était
introduit en europe sera envahi toute
l'europe puis aujourd'hui on est content
d'en avoir de la patate mais à l'époque
c'était un risque énorme parce que je
veux dire c'est que prend des risques
n'a pris les risques on prend
constamment des risques mais ces risques
en fait sont pas si grand que ça et le
risque d ogm surtout surtout si on fait
du christopher cazenove se dire qu'on on
sait exactement ce qu'ont fait qu'elles
sont modifications seront apportées à la
dn1 le risque est alors beaucoup plus
contrôlés que des risques que l'on a
pris dans le passé dit parfois tu les
ogm c'est bien mais il faut super bien
des contrôles et reese le chef sont
super bien contrôler surtout en europe
en europe
super afin ya tellement une opinion anti
ogm qu'on est maintenant super attentif
à tout nouveau gm en europe et qu'on
fait énormément de test des tests que
des des méthodes d'hybridation d autres
méthodes plus classiques ne passerait
pas bref tout ça pour dire que
l'argument principe de précaution il est
noble mais n'est pas plus tenable pour
fait beaucoup moins tenable pour les ogm
que pour plein d'autres méthodes
classiques d'agriculture qu'on a utilisé
depuis cent mille ans
le troisième argument c'est que utiliser
des joueuses des ogm ça pourrit sol
parce qu'on utilise plus de pesticides
et ça c'est mal comprendre les ogm parce
que ça c'est l'argument est donc
totalement recevable il totalement voix
et même pour certains ogm
ces ogm là ils sont associés aux 6m ans
monsanto avec sur lequel il y avait pas
mal de documentaires et il ya un
amalgame aussi entre monsanto les ogm et
monsanto n'est pas des ogm monsanto quel
autre chose que des objets des
herbicides et pesticides
et puis il ya des élèves qui sont pas
produites par monsanto d'ailleurs
monsanto n'est pas le seul producteur de
gm mais pour en revenir aux pesticides
oui certains ogm conduit à une
utilisation de plus de pesticides
c'était très très très mal mais il
yad'autres aux jeunes qui sont bien plus
adapté pour le problème des pesticides
part de certains ogm dans lequel on
inclue dans l'adn de la plante un
fragment de gènes qui permet de coder de
produire des insecticides ou des
pesticides et à ce moment là on peut
contrôler beaucoup mieux la quantité de
pesticides y aura dans la plante et
s'assurer qu'on soit capable de déjà de
mettre une pesticides uniquement à
l'intérieur de la plante et pas partout
dont sol et plus partout et ensuite on
sera capable de comme ce soit bien
localisés on sera capable d'en mettre
beaucoup moins ce qui rendra la
nourriture beaucoup plus saine
donc en fait c'est possible de faire des
une deux à nourriture plus saine que la
nourriture bio ou la nourriture à celles
qui utilisent des pesticides en
utilisant les bons ogm quoi
techniquement techniquement c'est
possible le diable s'est passé peut-être
pas ce qui est fait non pas ça des
entreprises
mais techniquement c'est possible de
faire des ogm qui soit mieux en plein de
sens en termes de productivité en termes
de résistance aux
au poste et aux insectes en termes de
consommation d'eau nécessaires en termes
de production de vitamine à l'intérieur
de la plante n'est capable avec les aux
jeunes de ne pas d'optimiser un peu plus
les plantes et ce que l'on produit
enfin un quatrième argument anti ogm qui
est l'argument anticapitaliste souvent
quand on parle de gemmes on associe les
ogm ou grande entreprise et/ou et ça
c'est ça qui se carrément après je suis
d'accord pour dire que c'est un problème
c'est un problème d'aujourd'hui face à
un problème sur la manière dont les ogm
sont utilisées par l'industrie avantage
vraiment incroyable de claix sparkasse
neuf c'est que c'est rapide et pas cher
du coup on peut faire maintenant de la
manipulation du cinétique à très faible
coût et ça ça veut dire qu'on va être
capable d'explorer les possibilités
génétique beaucoup plus rapidement à
bien plus faible coût si bien que les
jauges m du futur sans doute leur prix
va baisser et va avoir plus de
compétition et à limite le poids ne sera
plus de comment réussir à contrôler
toute cette quantité de deux de gm
différents je pense que le vrai débat
bioéthique c'est sur les ogm ça doit
être ça se sait plus comment bien
contrôlé notamment la possible multitude
des ogm possible qui va sans doute
arriver maintenant qu'on a que les
sports casse 9
alors moi bien sûr de façon idéale ce
que j'aimerais c'est que typiquement pas
de brevet tease à sion des espèces des
génomes des espèces et que tout soit
beaucoup plus open-source qu' on puisse
fabriquer de façon un peu collaborative
décevant ce qu'elle était des séquences
d adn de semences que l'on pourra
ensuite mettre en place
à grande échelle dans l'agriculture et
ce de façon open-source de façon
facilement accessibles je sais pas dans
quelle mesure c'est faisable en vrai
peut-être mais peut-être que le lobby
doit de plus cela je ne sais pas ce
brave ce que j'ai envie de dire aux
anticapitalistes
c'est que si on fait lieu de mieux la
recherche et plus de recherches sur nos
gènes eh bien elle les coûts vont
pouvoir chuté et il sera peut-être
possible d'avoir plus facilement moins
de grosses entreprises et détruit plus
indépendant plus peut-être même
gouvernementaux qui seront capables de
mieux gérer la production ou la la
synthèse des nouveaux ogm
donc globalement les ogm il ya des
dangers communs qu'il ya des dangers
c'est indéniable sinon peut-être pas
aussi grand que ce que l'on peut
prétendre parfois dans la presse mais
ils sont quand même présents
et si beaucoup de scientifiques sont à
fond derrière les ogm étant très content
de la décision de du département de
l'agriculture américain
c'est parce qu'ils y voit énormément de
potentiel sur les ogm et c'est important
d'insister sur le potentiel des ogm par
exemple il y avait le cou du riz doré
aux philippines qui proposait de faire
d'ajouter en morceaux l'adn qui connaît
pour la vitamine a et de mettre ça dans
les plantations de riz aux philippines
parce qu'il y avait énormément de
carence en vitamine a et des gros
problèmes de santé aux philippines à
cause de cette carence en vitamine a et
donc inclure le rideau riz à l'intérieur
de ce riz aurait pu ne quasiment pas à
fêter vous dire quasiment pas affecter
les production locale de riz mais
d'ajouter dans cette production locale
cette vitamine qui pourra sauver des
vies beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de vies
dont beaucoup voient dans les ogm cette
possibilité cette capacité à sauver des
vies
en fait si on fait de meilleurs ogm et
concret gül bien les ogm vous serez
peut-être capable d'avoir des champs
agricoles qui sont beaucoup plus
rentables beaucoup plus efficaces donc
plus productifs avec ils produisent en
plus de la démo tueur de meilleure
qualité
c'est vraiment avec la vitamine que l'on
veut et qui peut possiblement aussi
qu'on sera moins d'eau et de pesticides
et du coup on sera peut-être capable
avec de la recherche pour ce g20 ont
fait plus de recherche est capable de
produire de la tour de meilleur deuxième
mais on serait capable peut-être de
faire des agricultures bien meilleurs
sur tous les points de vue qui soit
peut-être aussi d'ailleurs plus
compatible avec la biodiversité parce
que l'un des grands clubs de la
biodiversité en fait c'est vraiment de
l'agriculture et en avant l'agriculture
exactement la monoculture qui fait que
l'on impose à la nature une certaine
variété unique et que les espèces qui ne
sont pas adaptés à cette variété unique
belle espèce déjà celles qui sont fait
raser parler fort et qu'on a rasé puis
celles qui sont pas adaptés à cette
monoculture cette variété unique et de
culture elles vont disparaître donc le
gros couac à biodiversité
cc plus l'agriculture et peut-être
qu'avec des bourreaux j'aime il serait
possible d'avoir des cultures qui soit
plus variés à certain sens et ainsi
permettre une meilleure biodiversité
alors ce que je dis là
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr qu'il existe
la technologie pour le faire mais ce que
pourquoi j'aimerais insister c'est que
s'il ya encore plus de recherches sur ça
et notamment avec l'espoir place note
qui va accélérer la recherche dans ce
domaine
je connais pas tout le potentiel que
poids avoir l'utilisation des ogm
ils ont en tout cas ce potentiel là est
impossible a réfuté aujourd'hui et si on
fait de la recherche sur les ogm c'est à
dire sont investis aux ogm ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas aujourd'hui en
europe
peut-être que on arrivera à résoudre des
problèmes comme la biodiversité n'est
pas résoudre mais elle est en tout cas
dans le sens du meilleur biodiversité à
l'aide des ogm on voit ya pas de raison
d'opposer à priori aux jem et
biodiversité
bref pour finir cette vidéo j'aimerais
vraiment insisté sur le potentiel que
pourraient avoir les ogm et qui espère
casse 9 si on utilise bien sûr à bon
escient
sap loi vraiment sauver à la faim dans
le monde
tu as inventé vraiment la rentabilité la
qualité de vie de tellement de gens
résoudre la faim dans le monde
résoudre aussi des maladies j'en ai pas
parlé mais avec l'espoir casse n'a
offert que des manipulations génétiques
et tout un projet qui a été mise en
place pour exterminer de moustiques et
ainsi exterminer la marianne la malaria
ou paludisme c'est la même chose qui
aujourd'hui tuent des centaines de
millions de personnes dans le monde
donc avec tree sport casse neuf mois il
ya d'autres problèmes en choix bien sûr
mais avec christophe kass 9
on pourrait résoudre des problèmes qui
semblent insolubles aux joueurs de vie
comme par exemple éradiquer la malaria
et sauver des millions de vies 1 ces
sont des centaines de milliers par an
deux cent mille par an au bout de cinq
ans 16 millions de vies avec la
manipulation génétique et elle j'ai
presque envie de poser le problème
al'inverse que c'est que sachant qu'on
pourrait sauver des millions de vies
est-ce qu'il est éthique de ne pas
utiliser la manipulation génétique pour
sauver ces millions de vies voyez aussi
les propositions d'utiliser
modifications génétiques pour changer
l'adn
certes un embryon est par exemple et
donc soigné à l'état embryonnaire des
maladies génétiques
ce qui ce qui est tout un truc
incroyable ça pourrait bien améliorer la
vie des gens qui du coup ne serait pas
malade de certaines maladies
mais à un verre cela on est calme tout
près aussi de la manipulation génétique
à outrance de l'espèce humaine est
quasiment créé des espèces humaines sur
mesure sa propre boutique compliqué là
pour le coup je n'ai aucune opinion
bref c'est un débat bref c'est un débat
très complexe très compliqué et le
niveau technologique que l'on a et de
notre compréhension aussi du contexte
biologique durant lequel on est sont
indispensables pour se faire une bonne
idée de quels sont les labos quelle est
la bonne ligne éthique qu'il faudrait
peut-être avoir sur ce genre de problème
et malheureusement je pense qu'il est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
de d'opinion qui sont faites sans prise
en compte notamment des avances et
biotechnologiques de ces dernières
années et je vous invite vraiment a près
avoir vu cette vidéo notamment à en
parler avec vos amis s'ils avoir un
débat et si vos amis sont prorogés ogm
essayer d'être anti ogm et s'ils sont en
team j'ai essayé d'être pro jamais
vraiment pesé le pour et le contre
vraiment créer créer un débat je vous
invite à faire ça avec vos amis votre
famille mais aussi dans les commentaires
de cette vidéo donc n'hésitez pas à dire
ce que vous pensez des ogm j'essaierai
aussi devait animer un peu les débats de
de répondre à vos questions
je vous invite encore une fois à les
regarder la vidéo de david o après
pouvoir dans la technique crise peur et
je vous invite à aller écouter cet
épisode de podcasts science qui a
énormément remis en cause tous les
préjugés que j'avais sur les ogm